oh
my god
today's topic uh preacher's favorite boy
skippy jesus skippy
skippy's back baby hi i'm skippy and
this
is my you know i'll let her introduce
herself i do know her name though
i'm taylee but that might be his cover
for forgetting my name
no i totally did not forget
your name okay get it her name is taylor
shut up
totally totally not
come on not no and i had said at the
beginning
um would you like us to video this and
she's like no that does not sound good
what was your reason for not wanting to
um it sounded awkward yup and now
we're watching yeah yeah yeah
videotaping dates is super awkward i
don't know what to tell you
skippy it makes people feel
uncomfortable when there's something
recording their every move on a date
and the fact that you're making more eye
contact with the camera than her yeah
probably not the greatest thing for your
success rate but
what do i know because there's no
telling whether or not we'll
ever go out again right yeah so i just
wanted to make that
yeah no i get it you don't want to go
out with me again or there's or you're
not sure if you would ever want to go
out with me again i get that
i re i speak girls sometimes
it's the same as like oh yeah i get that
god bless you
uh i'm not smitten uh yeah sure
like yeah like
what i know i totally didn't look at you
boobs
so i know i know why this works i feel
like he's trying to get pity dated like
if he just speaks poorly about himself
enough to go back i'll give him another
date like
yeah i know i know you would never want
to go on i would never want to go
on a date with me again is it jack is it
jason is it tim
oh hey there tracy it's skippy i know
you would never want to go on a date
with me again but i give you my blessing
to kiss him
you're gonna love kissing her you are
crazy
okay so they went on their date the
dates are kind of interesting but not
too crazy
i've added the bonus footage probably
towards the end of the video or maybe
the patreon so you have to check
but this is after the date they go back
to her place
and there's somebody behind the camera
press play
press play by the way uh can the person
filming us uh turn around and show
himself just super quick
because we've got a guest filmer okay so
he's not going to do it but
that is my brother her brother braelyn
is super awesome
[Laughter]
and she decided to bring her brother for
the movie portion
she probably was like fearing for her
life and she's like bruh
i'm not going to end up on the first 48
so my brother's coming to this date
girl why did you go i mean she doesn't
know skippy
maybe she approached him enough for his
brother to be there
i just the end of the date why is he
there because maybe halfway through the
date they had this whole thing planned
right
and then by the end of it she was like
yeah we're going to watch them live in
my place because that's what they
planned
but then she told her brother she could
still say no she could still say no ruff
how many people are terrible at saying
no and that's what i'm talking about but
that's a real thing
some people have a hard time especially
if a dude's persistent or something like
that
you could feel a little bit cornered in
that moment sure you know what i'm
saying
and we know right women won't just leave
a date they'll call their girlfriend
although it takes her girlfriend called
me right people have we and we know and
we don't keep these persistence okay so
too much coco
she doesn't know what she's uh what
she's just won herself
um but she just got
a skippy uh skippy gift bag which
includes a
say skippy loves it should be likes but
uh for you
uh you got the skippy loves me you've
got uh
the skippy horrible you got the skippy
sticker
what do you get
these are from like february so this is
old and so is this are you kidding me
those things never go bad
yeah and then there's also a
heart-shaped sucker
and then you've got a uh skippy my very
good mormon friend
uh pin and then you also get
the thing that has been given out for
two years in a row now at the sundance
film festival
they thanks to skippy i
oh my god
what the [ __ ] is written on that whistle
what
i gotta think hey man if skippy gets a
second dude he deserves it
i'm on the twilight zone
legitimately i'm confused is she still
alive
if anybody lives in the area i think
they're they're from utah i could be
wrong
that's where all the mormons live can
anybody check in on taylee
taylor if you're alive can you leave us
a comment please
please shall i proceed no what the f
what's that what incarnation was that
huh i don't even want to do this anymore
we shouldn't get it down what how many
creatures done we're good
we're stopping this nah man this is not
worth it
[Music]
foreign
so we watched it the three of us so it
wasn't the most romantic thing but it's
not a romantic movie well i'm pretty
sure that there's no way
that that could have been so it's yeah
totally
it's but it gets it on
we got to sit on the loveseat while
watching it
but um we didn't like touch hands or
anything like that i would consider it
it was the like
seat not a love seat right hold it
hold it thank you and hold it for the
rest of it because i haven't smashed
your phone
the like seat
speaking of the like seat this is a good
opportunity for you to hit that like
button
uh help us out with the youtube
algorithm show your support subscribe
because about fifty percent of you are
not subscribed
now back to preach
what's weird about skippy's not as he's
saying cringe thinks it's that the girl
is saying hey this is what reality is
and skippy's like
but it's kind of a date i feel like
there's a disconnect between the two of
you that's very very evident i feel like
skippy doesn't want to acknowledge it so
he keeps saying weird stuff
thinking he can salvage it it's very uh
the like scene okay anything you want to
say
yeah or am i like saying like is it is
that a little too strong
word you think what about a friendly
seat
okay
[Music]
yes what do you mean in front of the
brother
she's she's clowning oh man
oh wow and people might be saying why is
she being so mean it's because skippy
can't take a clue
no if i say no to you you keep pushing i
say not interested you keep pushing
i said no at some point i'm like you're
disgusting you're not gonna be mean
yeah that's the thing there's steps to
this first people say it
vaguely then people are more precise
then they're straightforward
then they're mean and often before the
meme
they're clowning she's still clowning
that that actually brings us to this
okay so if we go on a date again are we
going out
she rolled her eyes did you see that
because she just said friends
so we go on a date it's not a date so we
go on this date right and she's like
oh this [ __ ] again just as friends or is
there like
or like is this a date this next thing
well well um if we were going just as
friends it wouldn't be titled date
it would be titled hanging out okay so
what
so yeah cause he's old and she's
clowning yo in my bending knees when
he's on the beat chop king king cank
if there's anything you guys can take
away from this is that yo y'all might be
failing but you're not feeling like
skipping
if there's anything you can take away
from this is kippy take him away
i mean all those people who thought they
were without hope if skippy can get
dates and [ __ ] it up this bad
you can also get dates that's right you
can get dates
so ball in your court what would you
like to do would you like to hang out
next or would you like to go on a date
next
um i would be fine with either
what's your preference like if you had
to pick one which would you
wow she just told you no i don't want to
hang out i don't want to date
i don't want to see you anymore that's
what it means man i just understood that
ancient chinese saying
death by a thousand cuts
and muff bleeding right now and you
don't even know
he's not reactive no i'm good why are
you so white
i don't know he's bleeding out
shang shank well do i do i have to
answer this on camera
yes on camera
really is there a difference between on
camera would it be different if it
wasn't
oh yes because see this is documented
and i'm not gonna have to go back and
like
look at this and watch this and remember
like but we'd definitely like to help
with that
hope you enjoyed this video taylee you
were a wonderful date
don't your don't you think your honesty
you know what that
never mind i think i know the answer
right skippy i would go on a second date
with you
date not friends hang out i just defined
the word
date so okay in that case you then get
oh my gosh you get another gift you do
he got me a bag
of intense dark chocolate oh yeah i did
get your jelly because i
love it still i'm zooming in on it i
love it it's got three layers
of chocolate love in there dark
chocolate
hey what's up taylee no i'm good i'm
good
what do you mean you i know you good i
said what's up taylee
cool yeah you gonna get some messages
man
from taylor nope i'm only accepting them
from taylor
there's one last uh thing here um do you
remember what i won
from you this year we're not doing that
on camera
uh we we're not but will you at least
say what i won from you
okay so we had a bet yep tell the bet um
i was grocery shopping and he called me
while i was grocery shopping so we were
on the phone
while i was grocery shopping and he said
what do you think
your groceries are going to come up to
and i said about 60
and he said i think it's gonna be less
than sixty dollars
so he said if i was closer
then i should get something right yeah
he should get something if he was closer
he should get something so he said he
would wash my two-minute up
he would wash my dishes if i won and he
said that if he won he wanted
a hug what kind of hug
i wanted a big hug oh a
big hug hey i want a really big hug and
you're doing all this skippy in front of
her brother
same same same same same same
same on you right yeah right okay so
here's the thing when i went shopping
two minutes left
okay so when i went shopping earlier
right uh-huh
i'm going to actually release her from
because i want a girl to want to hug me
i don't want her to have to hug me right
so i brought i brought her
a whole bunch of hugs i brought her
a whole whole bunch of hugs i didn't
know about it the problem yeah no of
course he didn't know about this and
she loves dark chocolate uh they didn't
have them dark chocolate
here's your whole bunch of hugs thanks
for the great date
these are my hugs that's our date that
was it okay
you can stop now how do i turn this off
is having trouble but it's a good end to
the date yeah so you
look to the um one of the best dates of
your life
no no shut the [ __ ] up
she said shut up
fergie shut up just shut up
shut up what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
nice taylor nice even the brother is
feeling bad for him
damn bro now the brother wants a hug hey
give me a hug man what are your thoughts
on uh skippy's uh
new other date don't film your dates
you can't huh can you fix a lack of
self-awareness i don't know
it's like the brother's right there in
front of her at this point i think he's
strolling
i don't know if he's trolling i think i
don't think i don't want to believe that
he has
so much lack of self-awareness at this
point i'm going to be
like i want to lie to myself and be like
you know what he's trolling
but he's also mormon and if you're
raised mormon and you're isolated from
people
you could get that like self-awareness
god damn you don't you think what i'm
saying i don't think it has nothing to
do with being a mormon
okay if you say so if you know anything
about mormons and you disagree or agree
let us know in the comments below
from what i've learned about mormons
this is not a completely crazy thing
because you have to imagine what their
lived experience is it's not it's not
like any other religion
why it's before see it's not like they
live like everybody else
so it's a different thing but anyways
all right grizzly i just when i watches
is just complete lack of self-awareness
to have that kind of weird conversation
after people being told no to say that
in front of the brother which is
unbelievably awkward to not take all the
hints and still push like it's just
it's desperation coupled with no
self-awareness it's
it's uh it's not a pretty thing to look
at but uh goddamn
unfortunately from uh what i watched on
skippy's channel doesn't get better no
it doesn't
i gotta stop sending you skippy videos
bro that's all i got
anything else no deuces
the whistle the whistle was it for me
man
it was a whistle for me